[Musique]
les nominés dans la catégorie
entreprises innovantes sont bonjour à la
batterie si j'ai 25 ans je suis
entrepreneur dans le digital
[Musique]
il est co op résumer en quelques mots
ça permet de retrouver sur smartphones
et tablettes et prospectus que l'on
reçoit souvent dans notre boîte aux
lettres et qui finissent à la poubelle
bien souvent l'entrepreneuriat peut être
véritable tremplin justement pour la
jeunesse martiniquaise pouvoir
s'émanciper pouvoir faire des choses
qu'ils aiment réellement faire c'est une
application aujourd'hui qui a été
téléchargé plus de onze mille six cent
fois alors c'est ce que nombre de
lectures des catalogues aujourd'hui on
est on a déjà dépassé les 300 mille
lectures des catalogues sous
l'application mon rôle à moi c'est de
transhumance et les catalogues sous
version papier sous version numérique
solutions digitales et des larmes
accessible sous tous les supports que ça
sera sous android ios et tablettes sur
nous j'ai vraiment arrivé après mes
études après un master de management
international puis ça me permettait
aussi de revenir en mars y arriver c'est
une solution au niveau de la plate forme
en ligne
le restaurateur mais sa carte en ligne
et puis il ya une commande
l'ivoire la mise à disposition de
l'ivoire c'est à dire que soit on
demande un livre pour une période
définie dans l'élan va une fois pour
cette période
un bac s après gta le gc l'école de
gestion et de commerce et la martinique
et puis je suis parti faire un master 2
ans à paris avant de monter mon charisme
[Musique]
bonjour donc moi je suis aurélien filet
je suis le président cofondateur de bach
foule j'ai 26 ans je m'occupe entre
autres de toute la partie marketing
communication et commercial de la marque
je m'appelle bruno louisfert j'ai 24 ans
directeur général et co fondateur de la
boîte foule
bach full tilt novak de bière antillaise
ça fait une offre n'existe sur le marché
hexagonal et des gentils française donc
loi de l'opulente inique une somme une
marque de bière on a donc créé notre
premier produit qui la bière chabine
quitte une bière artisanale aromatisés
donc aux trois bandes et à la grenade et
à la nana le nom bac foule est inspiré
du créole sainte luciens mon bac foulant
et même au site de langlade foule et
puis le nom le nom même de la bière six
bières chabine donc voilà c'est dit
qu'il ya des bières blondes des brunes
des murs blancs chenaux effet une bière
tiède
ensemble nous sommes plus forts mais il
faudrait consommer janvier y arriver et
je rappelle que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
donc à consommer avec modération